[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo enlace
Norteamérica desde Nueva York aquí en
sus ciudadanos están acostumbrados a
convivir con las ratas en sus calles
pero en los últimos meses el número de
avistamientos de estos roedores ha
crecido un 71%. los expertos aseguran
que es debido a que durante la pandemia
mucho más gente cocinaba en sus casas
generando más residuos y por tanto una
fuente más de alimentación para las
ratas eso sumado a que desde el verano
de la pandemia los restaurantes salieron
a las calles además la suciedad en estas
calles en el metro y ciento de coches
abandonados en toda la ciudad que se han
convertido en las casas de estos
roedores hacen que la situación no sea
nada fácil de solucionar
[Música]
el alcalde de la ciudad de Erika Adams
ha lanzado varias iniciativas para
acabar con esta invasión de ratas Pero
ha sido suficiente el esfuerzo qué más
se puede hacer quizá los ciudadanos de
la gran manzana se han acostumbrado a
convivir con estos incómodos vecinos
estas y otras preguntas las
contestaremos en el programa de hoy en
Nueva York hay más de dos millones de
ratas es la segunda ciudad de Estados
Unidos con más roedores por detrás de
Chicago por eso para Jonathan lions fue
fácil meterse en la piel de uno de estos
animales y entender el problema desde
dentro las ratas no son el problema es
la comida que se tira y la basura lo que
tenemos que hacer es invertir más dinero
en limpieza y limpiar nuestras calles
mejor además de limitar la comida que
tiran los restaurantes para conseguirlo
badirad que es el nombre del personaje
ha colaborado con el departamento de
limpieza de la ciudad con ellos trata de
concienciar a la sociedad y evitar que
las calles de la gran manzana se llenen
de basura y desechos
creo que las ratas viven en Nueva York
muy bien por el sistema de metro
muchas áreas subterráneas para que se
escondan y puedan crecer no teníamos
tantas en la calle antes arriba pero
ahora buscan la basura y el problema es
que aquí no tenemos contenedores y nos
toca poner la basura directamente en la
calle
el metro de la ciudad es el principal
Refugio de los roedores cuando llega el
frío la suciedad que acumula las vías de
tren aumenta la gravedad del problema
pero hay más factores esto que venden
detrás de mí es otro de los grandes
atractivos para las ratas en esta ciudad
bolsas llenas de desechos que se sacan a
la calle a cualquier hora del día a
pesar de que esté prohibido por la ley
el alcalde también ha intentado luchar
contra esto limitando las horas en las
que se puede sacar la basura a la vía
pública pero como ven no hay nadie que
imponga la ley y esta solución tampoco
está resultando muy afectiva
hemos limitado el tiempo para que la
gente saque las bolsas de basura a la
calle desde las 4 de la tarde hasta las
8 de la noche no tiene sentido que las
bolsas de basura estén en la calle
durante tanto tiempo se han convertido
en un menú de abierta para los roedores
que van a estas bolsas y Crean un
problema real de salud en nuestra ciudad
ahora serán 4 horas menos que antes para
sacar la basura
otra de las medidas que incluye el nuevo
plan del alcalde es que las obras de
construcción contraten sus propios
servicios de Exterminio de roedores por
eso pueden ver este cartel colgado
estamos hablando de desechos y basura
rara vez verán todas las agencias que
están interviniendo en este caso unidas
Unas con otras todas bajo el grupo de
limpieza de Nueva York además tenemos
una agencia que colabora con nosotros
para identificar miles de áreas que
necesitan de una limpieza intensa
además se han destinado 22 millones de
dólares al servicio de limpieza y 200
trabajadores más aún así parece que no
ha sido suficiente este edificio que
están viendo detrás de mí pertenece al
alcalde Erick Adams y está infestado de
ratas por eso acaba de recibir una multa
300 dólares que se suma a otras muchas
que ya tenía él asegura que se ha
gastado cerca de 7.000 dólares en
intentar exterminar las ratas pero nada
ha funcionado ahora su contrincante
político le ofrece una solución un tanto
curiosa es carti Silva contrincante
político de Eric Adams y activista al
frente de Guardian Angels una
organización que vela por el bienestar
de los ciudadanos ha venido a esta zona
de la ciudad donde las ratas se están
haciendo con las calles para ofrecerles
una solución
La idea es animar a la gente en el
bloque a que adopten un gato son gatos
salvajes
lo pueden tener fuera con esta caseta
ponen un poco de comida y agua y estos
gatos se quedarán y ningún ratón o rata
se acercará Porque pueden oler a estos
gatos
La casa del alcalde es lo que atrae las
ratas porque han entrado en el bajo del
apartamento y nadie vive allí
el equipo incluso limpia la vía pública
por eso aquí todos le quieren
El problema es que tienen coches como
este son desechos no funcionan y por la
noche salen las ratas que sean escondido
Porque ahora mismo las ratas están
durmiendo
aseguran que las tradicionales trampas
ya no funcionan
otra trampa de ratas esto no hace nada
absolutamente nada y otra más lo único
que hace es que cuestan miles de dólares
las ratas salen de aquí por la noche e
inundan en el barrio inunda en el barrio
y la solución pasa por gatos salvajes
como este estos gatos andarán Por los
alrededores pero estarán en este bloque
no abandonarán el bloque porque la mujer
que está dentro de la casa les pone
comida aquí fuera les pone agua un
Aliado perfecto para el Exterminador de
ratas que busca el ayuntamiento de Nueva
York el candidato ideal tiene instinto
asesino recibirá un sueldo de hasta 170
mil dólares hasta aquí nuestro programa
de hoy si le ha gustado Y quiere volver
a disfrutarlo puede hacerlo a través de
nuestras redes sociales o en nuestra
página web france24.